[Music]
hi guys i'm matt welcome back to my
kitchen several months ago i had the
opportunity to produce a video with the
joe sasto where he made donuts in 15
minutes using biscuit dough i thought
this was a super creative way of not
following the package instructions as a
fun challenge kelly and i tried to come
up with as many unique ways of cooking
with the biscuit dough without using an
oven here's how you can microwave pan
fry steam boil grill
oh and deep fry biscuit dough let's do
it we're going to start by using the
microwave to make pizza in a mug while
this recipe may only fit the loose
definition of pizza it's really really
good and it's probably the easiest
recipe i'm going to show you today
come on
not too bad i'm going to take one
biscuit and place it inside a
microwave-safe mug and i'm going to
microwave this for about 30 seconds
until it puffs up
so as you can see it's risen just a
little bit and bring in my marinara
sauce and we're just going to bring it
to the next level we're going to judge
it a little bit i'm going to add a
little bit of garlic powder and just a
little bit of dried basil
and i'm just gonna spoon this sauce
right on top
there we go and of course no pizza is
complete without its toppings so i'm
going to add a little bit of shredded
mozzarella and some mini pepperoni and i
actually like to place them in the
middle because as this microwaves it's
going to expand they're going to kind of
move to the outside before we throw this
back in the microwave get something like
a paper towel just drape it over the top
and throw it in there for about 30 to 45
seconds and you should be done
and there you have it look at that the
pepperonis have curled up all nicely i'm
just gonna garnish this with a little
bit more dried basil you may think
you're done you're not you know how hot
regular pizza is this is a whole mug of
it it will burn your mouth let it sit
for like two three four five minutes or
not
[Music]
this recipe is so good for how
shockingly easy it is you should try
this but if you think this looks good
wait until the next recipe this next
method involves pan frying to make
peanut butter and jelly fritters i like
these because they're super versatile
you can use them as breakfast lunch a
snack dinner dessert whatever you want
these are sort of like homemade
uncrustables except they're entirely
surrounded by crust crustables now to
get started i'm actually going to flour
my work surface a little bit just so
that my biscuit dough doesn't stick i'm
going to take two biscuits roll these
out until they're nice and thin and
about five inches in diameter i'm going
to add peanut butter to one and then i'm
going to do the same thing with the
jelly take a little bit of water and
apply it to the outsides of the dough
and this is going to help make the seal
that we use to keep all of our toppings
inside so now it's time to very gently
put our sides together i'm gonna go with
the peanut butter one because i find the
peanut butter is thicker it doesn't run
as much as the jelly would i'm just
going to drop these two on each other
look at that and you really want to seal
this bad boy up because if you don't it
will leak and you'll get jelly all over
your pan and you'll have to make another
one and we don't want that and i'm just
going to punch out my little pb j
fritter i'm using a biscuit cutter here
you can use a cup just anything that's
big enough to cut all the way around wow
look at that pop it in the fridge for
about 30 minutes this is just really
going to let the seal come together my
pan has been heated over medium-low heat
just adding a little bit of ghee and the
reason you should use ghee for this is
the chance it can burn and ghee has a
higher smoke point and just place it
right down in my pan don't touch this
just let it go for about four to five
minutes i can tell it's nice and brown
on the bottom because the edges are
toasted which means it's time to flip
and
wow just repeat what you did with the
last step let it go for about three to
four more minutes and that my friends is
a peanut butter and jelly fritter before
i dig in i do want to elevate it a
little bit i'm adding a little bit of
powdered sugar this is totally optional
cut this guy in half
let's see what this guy is all about
these are a nice treat they're crunchy
on the outside they're nice and fluffy
on the inside they're gooey towards the
middle where the peanut butter and the
jelly kind of ooze out these are great
as a snack or can be enjoyed any time of
day these first two recipes have been
great but for number three we're
thinking a little bit out of the box
we're at the halfway point so we're
going to be using a steamer to make
biscuit bow buns i used to live next to
a shop that sold bow buns and they are
literally the best thing i would go all
of the time rather than using regular
biscuit dough this is actually the flaky
variety and that's what works with this
recipe and i'm just going to flatten
these out a little bit maybe about four
inches or so across
and this next step is optional but just
because i like things to be uniform when
i'm cooking i'm actually going to use a
glass here to kind of punch out a shape
i'm just going to add a little bit of
cooking spray
fold
each one of my biscuits in half and
there you have it four biscuit bowl buns
that's a tongue twister ready to go my
heat is cranked to medium high i have a
pot of water here coming to a boil over
it i have my steaming basket let's see
if we're ready
and i'm going to layer in my boughs
and this is going to go for about five
to seven minutes until nice and puffy
watch for steam
oh my goodness look at how puffy
delicately remove from the heat
after a few minutes your buns are going
to start to settle a little bit don't
let them sit for too long because when
they deflate all the way they're really
no good you can fill them with whatever
you'd like i'm going to be filling mine
with an assortment of pickled vegetables
pork belly some cilantro and mint and
there you are biscuit bowl buns
now it's not exactly like authentic bow
it doesn't have the same taste it's a
little bit more buttery it works so well
the bun is so light and fluffy it holds
everything so perfectly i really really
encourage you to try this it's time to
boil our dough to make mini pretzel
bites these are a super fun little snack
you can dunk it into whatever you want
they're great for a party they're great
for kids they're just really fun to get
started much like with the last recipe
we're going to be using flaky biscuits
for this cut them
into four equal-ish pieces and once your
biscuits are nice and cut up you're just
gonna roll them into little balls just
like that
so i have here a pot of boiling water
boom to which i'm going to add about
half a cup of baking soda bubble bubble
toil and treble cool so now that those
are combined the next couple steps
happen pretty quickly i'm going to take
my biscuits and just add them
and i'm just going to let those go for
about 30 seconds and then once they are
floating pull them off and add to a
parchment-lined sheet i'm bending the
rules just a little bit at this point
instead of just boiling these i'm
actually going to throw them in the
airfryer here to get them nice and brown
and crisp on the outside but before that
i'm going to top my little dough balls
with some butter and salt
i'm going to throw these in my air fryer
for about five to seven minutes until
they're done
ho ho baby look at
them oh no
it's okay we'll forget about you and
there they are biscuit dough pretzel
bites you can serve them with whatever
you want i'm actually gonna go with
nacho cheese
these are really good they're ever so
crunchy on the outside they're super
light and fluffy on the inside these are
so much fun they're so easy to make and
i hope you try them but now
let's get a bit complicated to move on
to number five we're going to heat
things up a little bit on the grill in
order to make cheeseburger bombs this is
what happens when you take everything
wonderful about a cheeseburger and
shrink it down into a nice almost
bite-sized piece my pan is heated over
medium-high heat i'm going to add a
little bit of olive oil then my ground
beef hamburger seasoning and a little
bit of salt
and i'm going to let this go for about
five to seven minutes until everything
is nice and brown i've drained off a
little bit of the excess fat not all of
it which means it's time to add my dijon
a little bit of worcestershire and
finally water
bring all of this together
it smells so good at this point the
mixture is pretty much done i'm going to
bring it to a boil and reduce to about
halfway i'm just dusting my work surface
with a little bit of bench flour take
one of your regular biscuits a little
bit more flour and i'm just going to
roll this out until it's about five
inches around take two pieces of your
american cheese and place them in the
center and then top it with about three
tablespoons of your ground beef filling
take all of the edges of your biscuit
bring them up together make sure none of
your filling is poking out and then
pinch it into a nice little seam and
there you are that's a cheeseburger bomb
i'm going to set this aside seam side
down and then finish up with my
remaining cheeseburger bombs
before we move outside to grill these
there's a couple things we have to do
first i'm going to apply an egg wash to
the top of all my cheeseburger bombs and
then i'm going to top everything with
sesame seeds
and i'm just going to let these go for
about 20 to 25 minutes until they're
done
look at how beautiful they are not to my
own
[Music]
look at that these look fantastic uh
let's see idiomini you
and you
look at that
your biscuit you got your hamburger meat
the cheese on top allows it to melt down
and kind of cover everything bon appetit
these are just really good they read
exactly like a burger you've got the
beef you've got the cheese you've got
the ketchup you've got the bun even got
the sesame seeds on top if a
cheeseburger and a dumpling came
together and had a beautiful baby it
would be the cheeseburger bomb we're
wrapping things up today by deep frying
in order to make deep fried frozen ice
cream there's no better way than to end
things on a sweet note and this is a
really fun cool crunchy way of doing
that at least four hours before you do
anything you want to pop your ice cream
balls in the freezer just to make sure
they're frozen solid so they don't melt
while you're working with them in order
to make all of them nice and uniform i
just took a cookie scoop like this and
divided each portion in half toss this
back in the freezer until you're ready
to actually start forming them take six
biscuits and cut each of them in half
and then roll those out as thinly and
uniformly as possible be careful not to
tear the dough or to let it stick in any
way because if you form any holes in
your ice cream it's going to leak out
while you fry it in order to shape the
ice cream balls you need to work really
quickly take one piece of dough and my
advice for handling the ice cream
actually use chopsticks or cold spoon
that way you're minimizing that hot
contact place your ice cream in the
middle and then fold
all the edges
up and you want to make sure that
there's no gaps no nothing no leakage
and there you are just repeat with the
remaining balls these are our 12 perfect
little ice cream balls these need to sit
in the freezer for an additional one to
two hours just to firm everything up i
have good news and i have bad news the
good news is it's time to fry our ice
cream the bad news is we still have a
couple hours to go before we can
actually try it my pot of oil is heated
to 325 degrees fahrenheit and working in
batches i'll add about four frozen ice
cream balls at a time
these are going to cook in the pot for
about two to three minutes until they're
nice and golden brown on the outside
once they're nice and brown just place
them on a paper towel lined baking sheet
to let them drain
now i said there was bad news and that's
because there's one more phase of
waiting these need to go back in the
freezer for an additional hour so they
can firm up again oh my goodness i was
beginning to think we wouldn't get here
now you can top it with whatever you
want i'm gonna go with the classic
chocolate syrup whipped cream and
sprinkles
[Music]
you know something's good you can't even
muster the words to kind of talk while
you're chewing it it's perfectly crunchy
on the outside but then you have the
nice soft cool ice cream on the inside
it takes a lot of time but if someone
gave me this
i would be impressed today i showed you
six ways of using canned biscuit dough
that don't follow the baking
instructions on the package we
microwaved it to make a mug pizza pan
fried it to make pb j fritters steamed
it to make biscuit bow buns boiled it to
make mini pretzel bites grilled it to
make cheeseburger bombs and finally deep
fried it to make deep fried frozen ice
cream let me know which one is your
favorite or if you have another creative
use for biscuit dough let me know in the
comments below or message me on
instagram and until then take care my
friends oh yes
[Music]
do
[Music]